الحرب في اوكرانيا
فهي انها دفعت البلدان الاوروبيه الى
التفكير حتى وان كانت تعيش بسلام ان عليها
الاستعداد لاي اعتداء محتمل الدول
الاوروبيه التي كانت في غالبيتها لا
تنفقوا الا مبالغ محدوده جدا على الدفاع
باتت اليوم تبذل جهدا كبيرا من اجل زياده
امكاناتها العسكريه ماذا ذكرته في ندوه
قبل ايام ان الاوكرانيين من دون دعم
المعدات الاوروبيه والامريكيه لم استطاعوا
ان يصمدوا في وجه الجيش الروسي ولو توافرت
المعدات من دون وجود عزيمه الاوكرانيين
على الصمود لما كانت المعدات لتنفع في شيء
انا فكرت في هذا الامر عندما كنت وزيره
لدفاع وشكلنا مجموعات من وحدات خاصه
يمكنها ان تتدخل سريعا قمنا بمنوره تدريب
مشتركه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وانشانا مصانع
مشتركه وانشطه مشتركه من خلال فرقه او
شيئا من هذا القبيل يجب تعزيز القدرات هذا
بالامكان تحقيقه بسرعه نسبيا وهذا يتيح
لاوروبا ان يكون لديها دبلوماسيه فاعله
اعتقدوا انه لا توجد ديبلوماسيه من دون
دفاع
[موسيقى]